octubre de 2019 esta es la primera
cumbre ruso africana en la historia
frente a 40 dirigentes africanos
reunidos en sochi vladimir putin no lo
oculta él quiere una cooperación mucho
más estrecha entre moscú y los países
africanos brasil y rusia es uno de los
10 proveedores más grandes de productos
alimenticios en el mercado africano
nuestro país participa de una iniciativa
que quiere aliviar la carga de la deuda
de los países africanos una seductora
ofensiva que inició hace varios años
como en 2018 cuando el ministro ruso de
asuntos exteriores sérguei lávrov
realizó una gira inédita por siete
países africanos el mismo año seis altos
funcionarios del continente
correspondieron la visita firmando
convenios con moscú en temas económicos
y de seguridad contratos que permiten a
varias empresas rusas extraer recursos
naturales bauxita diamantes oro petróleo
los acuerdos también abarcan la
construcción de 14 plantas nucleares
esta influencia rusa que creciendo en
áfrica resulta también notoria en el
ámbito militar a semejanza del grupo
wagner está armada privada de
mercenarios aparentemente trabajaría
para moscú aunque el kremlin no
desmiente entrenando al ejército y la
guardia presidencial en áfrica central
reprimiendo las manifestaciones contra
el beshir en sudán o la insurrección en
mozambique e incluso abasteciendo de
armas y combatiendo junto a la armada
del mariscal haftar en línea hacia el
primer proveedor de armas de áfrica
seguido de rusia y sin embargo a pesar
de los esfuerzos económicos diplomáticos
y militares de estos últimos años el
kremlin lo sabe su influencia en el
continente africano es todavía débil
comparado con eeuu europa o china